um sketching high dimensionality
very great can you hear me
very good so today is the final lecture
and i'm going to focus today on
dimensionality reduction especially
things related to the johnson lunastress
lemma
so what i'm going to focus on is the
following
we have you know a collection
of high dimensional
vectors and some
norm space
let's say xy up to x
uh n in rd
think of d is large
and we want to uh
you know find an embedding
let's call these uh actually vectors
this set is capital x
now we want to find embedding
f into
a simpler space and for us simpler is
just going to mean you know lower
dimensional
so
uh such that
the geometric structure is approximately
preserved so such that let's say for all
x and y and capital x if you like the
distance between x and y
that's similar to the distance between f
x and
f y okay
so i mean dimensionality direction here
is just kind of one um
one approach and a larger family of
approaches of
you know using metric embeddings to
embed
harder geometric problems into simpler
geometric problems
here it's getting simpler because we're
reducing the dimension
hopefully that makes our algorithms
faster or it makes our memory
consumption lower etc but you know this
kind of approach
is more general where it might not be
about dimension it might be about just
embedding into a different norm space
that's easier
so maybe your computational problem is
hard in the original norm
but you can embed into some norm that is
you know
easier to work with algorithmically
right
but you know here here that we're going
to focus on the case where this easier
norm is just let's say a lower
dimensional version of the original one
um and kind of one of the cornerstone
results in this area
is a theorem by john celine distress
which says that you know for all
such x
where x has some you know finite size
and for
all epsilon and 0 1 there exists an x
not from x to r m
where m is 1 or epsilon squared log n
such that for all points in the point
set
you have that the distances after the
embedding are similar to before the
embedding
multiplicatively the euclideans
you looking at euclidean norms
specifically
okay
and we do know that this bound is
optimal
exists point sets requiring
you know say the min uh well
uh let's say one reps on squared log n
dimension
as long as you know epsilon is not too
small
this was something i showed with casper
green larson
three years ago
anyone uh i'm sure many of you
have seen this some of you may maybe not
and if you haven't seen it you know um
you know a natural question is why
euclidean norm why not other norms
um i don't want to spend too much time
on that but that is something people
have studied people have studied
dimensionality reduction for other norms
as well
um and the results just aren't as
drastic
you know here any endpoint
subset of euclidean space can be
represented in dimension n minus one
right because you know you can translate
so one of the points is zero
and then now these endpoints span and at
most n minus one dimensional
subspace so you can embed it
isometrically in dimension n minus one
and from dimension n minus one we're
going down to dimension log n
right so we get this exponential
improvement in dimension and we're still
approximately
preserving the euclidean geometry and it
just turns out that you know for other
norms you don't get as drastic and
improvement in the dimension
for example for l1 if you want to
represent an endpoint subset of l1
isometrically
you need dimension and you know up to n
choose two roughly n squared
whereas if you want to multiplicatively
approximate
original l1 distances then you know we
can get down to dimension that's like
n so you get to square root your
dimension you don't get an exponential
improvement right
and you know there was maybe i'll just
cite one um
paper on this by uh
the so theorem and i'm not going to
state the exact theorem
but it's by uh let's say johnson and not
or
which says that
if a norm space
has the property
that all
endpoint subsets this for all n such
that for all n
and for all endpoint subsets
x x embeds
into an on a log n dimensional
subspace with constant distortion
then that nor that norman space is
almost euclidean
and you know what is almost euclidean in
their theorem
so and state the full theorem so you can
say this is a
high-level version of their theorem what
does it mean almost equating it means
that
any finite dimensional subspace of that
norm space let's say any k-dimensional
subspace of that norm space
embeds into euclidean space with low
distortion
specifically the distortion that they
proved was something like two to the two
to the log star k
but you know it's some slow growing
function of k okay so
what the theorem says is that kind of
the only norm space that
any normal space that has this jail-like
property
is is a norm space that's almost
euclidean for some definition of almost
euclidean
so um so we're going to focus on we're
going to focus on including in space
it's the one it's the space that
kind of has the best dimensionality
reduction
uh okay any questions john you look like
you had a question yeah
can you explain a little bit intuition
why this is the case
oh for their um theorem yeah just but
yeah that's a good
i don't know i'm not uh i'm not i'm not
uh i don't have a good
i personally don't have a good uh answer
for that dave i mean johnson not were
might but i'm not sure
well then maybe if you can tell us why l
y is so bad that could also help a bit
oh um i mean why
you said the l1 you can only get the
root and uh
yeah the best the best upper bound so
yeah so there's
actually for l one we don't have a tight
answer so
you know for the best upper bound is
basically uh if you want one plus
epsilon distortion
you can go from dimension and squared
you know and choose two
down to dimension you know roughly n
over epsilon squared
um but the lower bounds i mean they're
the lower bound there is something like
n to the one minus o of i think one over
log one over epsilon something like that
um you need
dimension at least to get distortion
one perception is the instance of this
hard set point explicit yeah yeah it is
explicit
it's some uh recursively defined
variant of the diamond graph uh
so i mean i think it's something like
you know the the very first
the very first lower bound for l1 um
[Music]
was you know that was i think by
brinkman and charlie carr
i forget the year but the very first
lower bound
basically you start with a graph that
looks like this
and then you kind of i think i think
it's something like you know for each
edge
you recursively like change the edge
into
itself a diamond or something like that
and you do that some you know log
logarithmic number of times um
and then as you do it you know you you
assign coordinates to these points
and then you get some you get some l1
metric and you prove that kind of the
um that thing itself has some distortion
lower bound
or some dimension lower bound if you
want to get low distortion
um but i mean i think
you know and this one which came later
um
i think if i remember correctly the
construction is quite similar it's just
instead of a four cycle you replace it
with a longer cycle
um but yeah i mean i don't want to get
into any of this uh
today
okay um
good so what else did i yeah so okay so
let's focus on euclidean space
so the original proof well actually
all proofs
first uh proof the following llama
which says you know for all epsilon and
delta in the interval from zero to a
half
there exists a distribution over
matrices
and for all d
such that for any vector
if you pick a random matrix according to
this distribution
the probability that that matrix doesn't
preserve that vector
in l2 norm
is at most delta
okay and you know the original
jl proof
uh d epsilon delta was you know a scaled
projection
onto a random
m-dimensional space of rd
but you know there's been and we'll talk
about that there's been kind of more
work in devising other
distributions that give the same result
and you know once you have the llama
so dilemma why does the limit imply the
jl lemma
you just set delta
to be less than one over and choose two
and then union bound
over all vectors
x of the form x 1 minus x 2 where
x 1 and x or x i minus x j sorry
where x i and x j are in this capital x
so um
oh and i should have said here right
what is m m is
one or epsilon squared log one over
delta
right
right here so um
right so because you're setting delta to
be less than one over n choose two log
one or delta is log n so you get the
jail
you get the jail
now today what i want to talk about we
have a limited time here
um i want to talk about you know
you know improving aspects of jail
and also applications
okay
so first let's do improvements
so one of them is let's say you know
runtime
so why might you want to do
dimensionality reduction as i mentioned
you have some high dimensional
computational geometry problem like
clustering
or nearest neighbor search or whatever
and
you know whatever your your algorithm or
data structures you know complexity it's
runtime it's memory consumption
whatever depends on the dimension in
some way and the higher the dimension
the more you know the more resources
your algorithm needs to use
so if i can first as a pre-processing
step reduce the dimension of my input
and then run my algorithm presumably my
algorithm now uses fewer resources
because working on a lower dimensional
problem
okay so right there so let's say let's
say the resource i can start with is
time
for example um
so there are two steps to this one is
the time it takes to do the
dimensionality reduction
and the other is the time it takes to
now solve the lower dimensional problem
so for the latter the lower the
dimension the better presumably right
because if i if i get a lower dimension
my algorithm now runs faster
but what about the former what about the
time it takes to actually do the
dimension reduction
okay um
so for that i want to have an embedding
that's fast
so the original jl
project projected
data
onto a random you know
m dimensional subspace
so some vector x gets mapped to pi
x where this pi is this random
projection
you know how do you how do you get a
matrix pi that's a random projection
well you need to you need to create you
need to get basically a random
or thermal basis right that's one way so
how am i going to do that
you know here's me forming a matrix
so you know here i'll just pick a random
gaussian vector and then i'll normalize
it
and then here i'll pick another gaussian
vector
and then i'll remove the projection onto
g1
right and then now i have
a uniformly random and normalize it and
now i have a uniformly random vector
that's
orthogonal to g1 and then some you know
and then
similarly uh you know i get g3 i
i remove the projections onto g1 and g2
onto the span of the previous stuff and
then i normalize it etc
right so basically i just take a
gaussian matrix and do gram-schmidt
right and then the projection is then uh
let's say pi
is then a a transpose right that's my
projection onto a random
to random subspace so this
um well actually i guess i can even
uh yeah something like that
so the point is this is a dense random
matrix which i don't even need to do i
can just uh
yeah oh okay that's fine so i can ask a
question
yeah uh so you're doing gram schmidt on
the columns but you've got more columns
than rows so eventually
yes i realize this picture is uh the
picture is
not the right picture so let's see so um
is this what i want
no no it's yeah it's exactly that's
exactly right it's exactly the other way
around right
so the point is i'm projecting to uh
a lower dimensional subspace right so
okay there now i'm happy with this
picture
okay all right so i want to pick an
m-dimensional subspace out of
uh d-dimension so this thing
this thing is uh d and this is a
but in fact now i can even just set pi
to be basically a transpose
that's fine that works okay okay
so anyway the point is that this is a
dense this is a
what don't i like about this i don't
like that this is a dense random matrix
in particular i don't like the word
dense here because dense means that
to do this mapping x that's mapped to pi
x is going to be slow
right so this is something that people
have studied
basically how to come up with a
distribution that satisfies
you know that gives you jl but is faster
and
um you know the history on that is first
there was aclioptus
and what he said was you know pick the
matrix pi
that each entry is you know plus minus
one over root m
or actually let's say plus minus 1 over
some scale factor let's not focus on the
scale factor
um and then what you do is
then for each entry
zero it out with probability two-thirds
okay so what he was able to show is that
you know
of course after you do this now
two-thirds of the matrix is zero so it's
sparser
it's only a third of the matrix is
nonzero and what he was able to show was
he could get the same exact m that
people were able to get in previous
analyses the same target dimension even
up to the constant factor
not just asymptotically not just in big
o um
with this sparser construction so you
know you you expect now that you can
embed things three times faster because
only a third of the matrix is non-zero
then the first work that got some
asymptotic improvement was by
ilone and chazelle and this was an o6
and their idea was why don't we choose
pi to just be a sampling matrix
so ideally we would you know look
something like this
each entry would have a one in a random
location
you know exclude some scale factor
in fact the scale factor just be root m
um actually sorry this is
the transpose of what i wanted i realize
so what i want is that every row has a
one in a random location
and then zero is everywhere else
so so this is a sampling matrix right so
if i multiply this by some high
dimensional vector
x then each entry in pi x is just a
random
or uniformly random sample from x and
you know it's you can it's not hard to
verify that the expectation of pi
x l two norm squared is x l two n
squared
so this gives you the right thing in
expectation right
but remember that other lumber that we
use to get jl says we don't just want
expectation we want that the probability
that pi x you know is too large pi
equals two number of squared minus x l
sub m squared is large
i want this to be small atmos delta
right
so we don't just want to reason by the
expectation we want we want to bound on
the probability of deviation and the
problem with this is
the variance could be terrible even
though the expectation is correct right
because imagine that
x has all its mass in one location
and then zeros everywhere else
then the variance from sampling is
terrible you're not even going to see
the weight unless you take d samples
right in expectation so
um the way that i learned chazelle fixed
this
was to basically do some kind of
preconditioning to x the idea is
pi will actually be the product of a few
matrices
and you know the first matrices there
their job is just to precondition x to
make sure that the mass is well spread
and then the final matrix will be this
the actual sampling
because once it's well spread sampling
works right if x had been
let's say one everywhere for example
then sampling has no variance
so the idea was to use their idea was to
use the uncertainty principle
which says that both a vector
and its fourier transform can't
both be well concentrated
okay um unfortunately
this it doesn't quite work either if you
you know so you could say well why did i
just now do pi
is a sampling matrix times the discrete
fourier transform
right so um i mean there are two things
that are wrong here
i mean there's one main thing that's
wrong but and then you'll see that it's
not
so you know it's it's working so let's
see what's wrong here what's wrong here
is that
um what if what if we have the opposite
situation where x is actually very
concentrated
now you apply f now you've after you
apply f
it's collapsed all its mass into one
coordinate or a few coordinates
now sampling doesn't work so you have
the opposite problem now where your
original vector might have been dense
and then after you apply the discrete
fourier transform it's sparse um
but it's you know it's and it's not
really just one or the other you can
construct
examples where a vector and its fourier
transform are both
you know evenly spread on root n and
root d root d coordinates
okay so kind of neither neither
the vector nor its fourier transform is
particularly well spread
okay so what they did do instead was
they actually put another matrix here in
the middle
where so now their construction looks
something like this this is the dft
actually not here sorry here okay
so here's your dft your discrete fourier
transform this is f
and then you have this diagonal matrix d
which has plus minus ones
on the diagonal and then now here you
have your sampling matrix
and then you have some scale factor okay
and now this is pi
and what they're able to show is that um
and if you if you call this matrix if
you call this matrix a which is the
product of these two matrices
then they can say that for all x the
probability that
um
if you look at the ratio of the l
infinity norm of ax
to its l2 norm
by the way i mean the l two number of ax
is just the same as the
l term of x right because
d and f are both isometries
um the probability that this thing is
large
is small so with high probability
um you do get kind of a well-spread
vector where
the definition of spread here is looking
at the ratio of the l infinity norm to
the l2 norm
and then now that you have a good spread
you can sample
okay and um you know they got
they got a good result here which
eventually led to basically m
being uh so if you if you want the
optimal m
you know one erupts on squared log n
then
unfortunately like even though you get a
pretty decent spread here
you don't get it perfectly well spread
so sampling doesn't quite work perfectly
so you do need to over sample compared
to the jail bound
but one you know one way to fix that is
to then here
at the very end let me actually put it
here
still getting used to changing to eraser
out of there we go
um so here you could put for example
a slow jl matrix like random projection
or something and then
set pi to be this and maybe i should
make it clear now that
um kind of sampling is getting you
part of the way there but it's it's not
it's not as good as you want
so you're able to reduce the dimension a
lot using sampling but not
not to the optimal bound and then you
wrap it up at the end by doing a slow jl
down to the optimal bound
there's a there's an optimization they
do in their paper that's a little bit
faster than this
but in particular instead of a sampling
matrix they just use kind of a random
sparse matrix
but qualitatively it's quite similar and
what you'll get is m being the right
thing
in embedding time
to map x to pi x
is now something like d log d to do the
fast fourier transform
plus some m cubed and this m cubed is
coming
is basically coming from the fact that
since sampling doesn't work optimally
you have to do this slow jl at the end
so that's giving you an additive mqt
okay
so there's been a bunch of work that i'm
not you know i have a little time i
don't want to get into all of it but
um you know the balance been improved to
m squared it was a
time squared by a load of liberty and
then there was a conceptual shift
that was kind of first
first it was you know not completely
crisp but it was there in ilo
and liberty in 2011 but kramer and ward
really made it apparent
um which is here we said
you know first condition on f times you
know let's call it this was d
first we condition on f times d being
good good meaning it spreads the mass
you know around and x we condition on
that good event and then once you
condition on that good event sampling
works with high probability
and kramer and ward and i loaned liberty
in 2011 had this kind of conceptual
maybe it was 2010 and this conceptual
shift where actually what you want to do
is instead you condition on s
times f being good for some definition
of good okay
and then once s times f has that good
property
then d gives you a good jl distribution
when you throw d on top of it and their
definition of good was that
s times f satisfies what's called the
restricted isometry property from
compressed sensing
which i'm not going to get into right
now but you can get some better balance
that way for the jail problem
okay so anyway this was one approach
this was the ilo and gisele approach
and then another approach
is to sparsify pi so going back to
going back to you know oculiotis's
approach in 2001 of
making a third of the entries non-zero
and zeroing out two-thirds of the
entries
um and here what was eventual so this
was you know
it was there was you know oculops
studied this in o1
and then there was uh das gupta kumar
and star lotion 2010 who they were the
first
they were the first to show that you can
get actually some asymptotic improvement
not just a factor of three um
and then you know kind of the
state-of-the-art bound now
is due to uh myself and daniel kane
in 2012.
and what we show is that actually the
count sketch for example
gives gives a nearly optimal bound so
remember what is the count sketch we
talked about it at the end of last
lecture
or was it or not not the very end but
near the end when we were talking about
the
frequent items problem and data streams
okay
um so here what does pi look like
remember like the the rows were divided
into these blocks
so if you look at a column
kind of in each entry we picked a random
location chosen by a hash function we
made that entry be plus minus one
and then the rest of the column was zero
then in this one we chose a random
location we made it plus minus one
the rest of that column is zero okay
so we let's say we have s blocks
which means s non zeros
per column
and the total number of rows here
is again m and we want we're going to
shoot for s being a little lower than
okay so we're actually going to get an
asymptotically sparse matrix
and the theorem is that
if you pick m to be 1 over epsilon
squared log n which is the jl bound
you can choose s to be only epsilon
times m
okay so you can get an asymptotically
sparser matrix and furthermore
this is actually optimal
up to a log one or epsilon factor in s
so there exist point sets where um
if you insist on having target dimension
meaning the jl bound one epsilon squared
log n
uh vl linear via linear map then this
the column wise varsity of that map has
to be at least
epsilon m divided by divided by log over
epsilon
and this was this this proof was due to
myself and
we win
okay
so um
if there are no questions about this i'm
going to move to
i want to move to applications
so the first one i mean i'm going to
focus mostly on two
and one i want to talk about k-means
clustering
and two i want to talk about um
you know randomized linear algebra
so let's say clustering
so you have a bunch of points in high
dimensional space
all right so let me try it let me try
and cluster them
and i want to find you know some cost
i'm giving some parameter k
and i would like to find k clusters so
for example let's say here you know k is
three
i would like to find kind of the best
choice of three clusters possible for
this data
and what does best mean it depends on
the objective function but here maybe
this is one cluster this is another one
and maybe this is
you know there's unfortunately there's
that outlier but he has to go somewhere
okay and k k-means clustering
is the goal really here is to find
cluster centers
y1 up to yk
oops okay
um and these don't need to be
in the original input
to minimize
the sum i goes from 1 to n of the min
j goes from 1 to k
of x i minus yj
l2 norm squared so this is the k-means
clustering problem
[Music]
okay and this is an np-hard problem but
there are heuristics that are common
like lloyd's algorithm
okay and as you might imagine
algorithms for this problem have run
times that depend on dimension
okay so you know can we speed it up
using random projection
and the answer is yes um and the first
so let's let me write that objective
function
again so we have we said the sum
i goes from 1 to n
the min j goes from 1 to k
of x i minus yj squared
we want to minimize this
over choices of y1 up to yk
and you know one claim
is that so okay so you know once once
you choose the y's so let's say going
back to that picture so you have a bunch
of points here you have a bunch of
points here you have some points here
and then now you have these clusters
what are these clusters these clusters
are just basically
i'm partitioning the points according to
the y's
so the first cluster is all the points
which are closest to y1
the second cluster is all the points
which are closest to y2 the third
cluster is the closest to y3 so the y's
are somewhere in here so like y1 is here
and y2 is here and y3 is here
okay um
so now you can say look you know instead
of just choosing the y's why don't i
choose the partition
you know and then then choose the y's
inside each partition
okay um i mean that's
so like you know i could basically have
min over partitions then min over y
into partitions etc that's going to give
me the same exact objective
if i choose optimally but now you can
you know
you can analyze this and say look once i
once i choose the partitions there's
actually a closed form solution for what
the optimal y
is for that partition so
you know if you fix partition
p which is p1 up to pk
then the optimal
choice of y i for pi
is just the centroid of the points in
that partition
so it's 1 over the size of pi
the sum over let's say
i prime and p i of
x i prime right it's just the centroid
and if you use that fact you can then
rewrite the objective function to say
that
the cost of a partition
with some you know simple manipulations
turns out to be
the sum j goes from 1 to k
of 1 over the size of pj
sum over i less than i prime in pj
of x i minus x i prime l 2 m squared
okay so this you can prove that this
identity holds
um and what this says is that the cost
function now
is a is a you know
linear combination of square distances
between points in the original data set
and the coefficients in this linear
combination are all non-negative
okay which means that if i approx
if i'm able to approximate all these
distances by one plus or minus epsilon
then the entire cost is approximated up
to one plus or minus epsilon
so this implies that
one plus epsilon distortion
embedding
of the xi's
preserves the cost
of any clustering
any partition up to one plus epsilon
okay so i can i can get such an
embedding you know do jl on the points
and now cluster the lower dimensional
versions of the
points and i'll still have a nearly
optimal clustering
for the original points so this implies
i can cluster
in dimension uh only kind of one reps on
squared log n
and still get a good clustering
okay
uh i see an open question from arnold
about peace stable sketches i'm guessing
that's old
there is a question on what if you if
you're in the lp space
whether you can use the p stable
distribution
variables to do the projection and joe
answered that the concentrations of
property and this is additional reminder
to that
all right right yeah the concentrate yes
right so
these gaussian random variables are plus
minus ones are some you know there's
some gaussian they have very good
tail bounds but that's right for a piece
stable the tailbones are really bad
um right and as i guess maybe arnold's
pointing out if you do a media and a
median is not it's not an embedding into
lp
if your estimator is a median right so
but if your purpose is to actually
for data storage just to more
efficiently uh
store the distance maybe you can repeat
the
the sketching for just to a number of
times so then you get actually good
right so yeah so this is a good point if
all you care about is a data structure
that lets you recover
distances right that's different than
wanting and embedding into l2
now specifically for euclidean space we
do know
we have a paint we have you know for
example so we there's a paper by
uh jeremy woodruff in 2011 that looks at
the question of just sketching
for lp right where you want to be able
to
you want one plus epsilon approximation
to the norm with probability one minus
delta
and you don't care that it's an
embedding you're allowed to sketch
however you want
into some data structure and
for that they can show that um
you can actually get a lower bound
that's again whatever squared times
log n uh just like basically the
kind of
yeah basically you'll get you'll get a
lower bound that's
like basically saying that it's similar
to jl um
now there's another related problem
which is dot products
uh let's say that i have a collection of
unit norm vectors
and i and i want a data structure let's
say these these are points x1 and xn
they all have norm at most one i want to
build a data structure so that later
anyone says query ij i'll return to them
an additive epsilon approximation to the
dot product between x i and xj
okay now if i do jl
and then round the target vectors you
know that will that will let me recover
dot products because you know i know
that
i know that x i minus x j l two n
squared is equal to
x i o two norm squared plus x j l two
norm squared
plus the twice the dot product right
so moving this around this is saying
that
x i dot x j is equal to
and let's say they're unit norm vectors
this is equal to one half
two minus x i minus x j l two number
squared
okay so if i if i'm able to approximate
the l2 distances
which i can get from jl i can estimate
the dot products
okay so i can use jl to do this
it turns out that for that problem jail
is actually
sub-optimal by a log factor
and there's a there's a it's it's known
what the optimal data structure is and
that was something that was done by
uh alone and clark hogg
okay in 2017. and actually even for okay
so
um i realize now for
even if you want a multiplicative
approximation to the distance
um jl actually has for
just for the data structural problem
like again the same setup you have n
vectors x went up to x n and when
someone says query
um query ij you need to return a one
plus epsilon approximation to the l2
distance between xi and xj
actually for that just doing jl and
storing the ternary vectors is not
optimal
so there's something better you can do
and that's that was shown by
uh indic and wagner and wagner tell
wagner
and i think tall is actually one of the
participants is he
no no he's not here i'm not sure if he's
here in the program but
um
okay and i forget the year for that
um but in some i mean there are models
where
jail is optimal like in the streaming
model if you're streaming a vector and
then you want to know it's l2 arm at
query time
with probability one minus delta you
want a one plus one approximation this
jram woodruff paper from 2011 does prove
that
the boundary it from jail is an optimal
bound
okay so that's aside from just embedding
that's kind of any sketching procedure
in the stream
so this is this is for multiplication
multiplicative approximation to the just
to distances and then this is
additive to the dot products
okay so let me go back anyway to
clustering there's more i want to say
um
now let's say that i have my points
actually let's do the following
so let's say i have four points
and i i colored them according to the
partitions they're in so there are two
red points one gray
gray blue point and one uh yellow point
um and let's and there are three
partitions and four points
i can write a matrix now which looks as
follows and let's say that these are
points
these are points 1 2 3 and 4.
i can write a matrix for this
corresponding partition that looks like
this
the number of rows is
four because there are four points the
number of columns is three because there
are three sets in the partition
um what's in partition one the red
partition
points one and three so i'll put a one
over root two here zero whatever root
two
and a zero y root two y two two is the
size of the partition there are two
points in this partition that's why
that's why it's two root two and then
point two is in partition two so there's
a one there
and then point 4 is in partition 3 so
there's a 1
in the fourth row
okay and then i can also
define a matrix a which is the data
matrix where basically
uh there's x1 x2 as rows
of x4 here okay
and it's a calculation but i promise you
it's true if you look at
um first of all what can you tell me
about xp it has orthonormal columns
so xp xp transpose
is a is an orthogonal projection and if
you look at
x pxp transpose applied to the matrix a
it basically replaces each row of a with
the centroid of its partition
so then if you look at a minus x p x b
transpose a
each row of that is the original point
minus the centroid of its partition so
it's exactly
the difference vector between you know
that x i and the corresponding y
j the y j for its partition so if you
look at the frobenius norm squared of
this matrix
this is just equal to the cost of the
partition
which means that you can rewrite k-means
clustering as
you know uh compute
the min over all partitions p
of the forbiddenious norm of identity
minus
xp xp transpose a for being storm
squared
and let me just call this um
which i'll just rewrite as the min
overall queue in a certain set
i'll give you a name
right where let's say the rank of keep
the rank of q
is also at most k so it's like
it's some kind of constrained low rank
approximation problem
right basically i'm saying that q has to
have low rank but in addition
it's not just an arbitrary low rank
matrix it's a low rank matrix that has
to be of the form
x p x b transpose or p is a partition
okay
so some kind of constraint limiting
approximation problem and
um what this paper was able to show so
this is due to
cohen elder
musco musko
and persu i think it was 2015
is that if instead you minimize identity
minus
q a pi transposed for being a storm
squared
right so pi pi is this like jl kind of
matrix
right then
the q you'll get will give you the
optimal value
up to one plus epsilon as long as pi
you know as long as pi has enough rows
in it so
if you have if you have your target
dimension m
being something like k over epsilon
squared
then it'll allow you to you know
approximately solve any constrained rank
approximation problem
including k-means clustering which is
just a special case of a low rank
approximation
constraint learning approximation
problem so this k is the
is the number of partitions right it's
you want to find k clusters
so it's completely independent of n jl
gave you a bound of log n
here they got a bound of k which is
independent of n
and actually more recently um
it was shown by uh rosin
let's see makarichov
makari chev and rosenstein
in 19 2019 that actually you can get
um log k
okay so you know kind of that's
and that's almost optimal there's also
there's a log k
the lower bound is that you need log k
over epsilon squared so up to that
epsilon inside the log it's optimal
so um kind of there's an example of j of
you know
random projection in action and you know
if you just
if just naively use a jailband you'll
get something
but if you um if you tailor the analysis
to your problem in this case clustering
you can get something that's even better
and and the final thing that i want to
show you uh was rant that
final application was randomized linear
algebra
um you know one of the things is
approximate matrix multiplication
and i'll say something about that least
squares regression
i'll say something about that and i
won't have time but you can also use
this
for a bunch of other problems as well
such as you know lower approximate low
rank approximation
or a constrained case as well
leverage scores estimation
column subset selection
and they're you know i suggest one of
the things you can look at is
uh there's a book called sketching
as a tool for i think
maybe numerical in algebra
and this is by by woodruff
you can take a look there so
approximately matrix multiplication
what's the idea there
the idea there is um you know i want to
compute so i have a big matrix
i have two big matrices a and b so let's
say
a
is um is a matrix which is
let's say a by n
and b is a matrix which is b by n
or n by b uh
this is what i want to do actually let's
let me let me uh
change this up a little bit
okay and i want
a transpose b so naively this would take
time which is like
a times b times n time
but instead what i do is i compute pi a
and i compute pi v and i compute pi
a transpose pi b right
and i would like to argue that that is
close to a transpose b
so i would like that for example you
know pi is a random matrix or the
probability
over pi that
pi uh a transpose
pi b minus the truth which is a
transpose v
probably this is large small
let's say small means delta large means
it's going to mean something like
epsilon
times the norm of a times the norm of b
and people have studied it also with
other norms like operator norm
but you can show that you know if you
just basically pick pi to be
a random projection matrix like a jl
matrix you'll get this kind of guarantee
um and you know you can basically pick
m to be something like one or epsilon
squared
times log of one over delta okay
that's your target dimension so now pi a
and pi b are smaller matrices think of n
is huge right
so remember a and b they're huge
matrices so
um you know they they have a lot of rows
let's say
so pi a has many fewer rows
they can have different number of
columns but they have a lot of rows
okay um and actually you know aside from
jail another thing you could do is
sample
so you can actually choose pi to be a
sampling matrix where
the probability that you that you you
know keep
the the i throw of a is proportional to
something like i think the l2 squared of
the row
and if you do something like that you
can get a similar kind of guarantee
and then regression
so you want to minimize let's say now
x beta minus y where
i'm looking at the case where x is a
really tall and skinny matrix
and instead of what you do so this is
this is beta ls this is the least square
solution
so that's the argument i guess
over beta so instead of using beta tilde
ls
which is the argument
of pi x beta minus pi y
right and you want to argue that this
beta tilde is approximately optimal
and that's something you can do as well
with those there are sampling approaches
i want to say a word about that but also
using kind of random projection
approaches and the key thing there it
turns out to be that you want
what's called the subspace embedding
property
which is you know if e
is a you know linear subspace
[Music]
there's only your subspace oh
sorry
um then
we say pi is and
epsilon subspace embedding
for e if for all x and e
if you look at pi x two norm squared
it's approximately x out to norm squared
so it's basically you know jl but we're
not doing jail in a finite set of points
you're doing it on an entire subspace
and it turns out that you can get in
this case m to be
o of the dimension of e
over epsilon squared and you know claim
this is called this is part of something
called the sketch and solve
so actually this here or this idea that
beta tilde is just going to be the
optimal thing for the sketched version
this this idea is called sketch and
solve usually in the literature
and the claim is that if you do sketch
and solve it works as long as pi is a
subspace embedding
so if pi
is a subspace in epsilon subspace
embedding
for the span of
y as well as the columns of capital x
remember we're trying to minimize
x beta minus y
then if you look at x beta tilde
ls minus y
you know it's almost optimal so you get
you'll get something like this
it'll do almost as well as the true as
the true least squares
optimal point theta and
you know this this has a one-line proof
which i'm you know i'm not going to do
now because i don't have time
um but then you know sketch and solve
and
and actually there are other ways of
arguing this as well so
there's another
it's it's actually also possible um
can also show this is in charleston's
paper charlotte's paper can also show
that
i'm being um
oh so what does this give you by the way
so the dimension here the dimension of e
in this case
is going to be basically z plus one
right because
pot the input matrix x has the most d
columns and then y is one more vector so
this says that you can map down to
dimension d
um roughly d over epsilon squared
instead of your original dimension which
is n
you can also show that in fact in this
case that d over epsilon works
and there's actually another argument
that uses subspace embeddings in a
different way
um where you can actually end up working
over dimension
d o of d independent of epsilon via an
iterative approach so basically
you use the subspace embedding as a way
to find
a good preconditioner for the matrix to
find a new matrix with the same column
space but with better condition number
and then you run gradient descent with
that matrix and you can show that
you only need like something like log
one over epsilon iterations of gradient
descent to get good error
and you're only ever working over
dimension d without the
poly one over epsilon dependence okay
uh so that's another thing you can get
and maybe the very last
thing that i want to show like slide
that that i'm gonna write anything on is
this one
you know how do you get a subspace
embedding
so one way as you do kind of jl over
a net of the subspace
but this is not always
doesn't always give optimal results for
example
if you remember with sparse jl
i said that you get m to be uh 1 over
epsilon squared log n
and s to be of epsilon m this would lead
to in this case for subspace embeddings
m to be
o of d over epsilon squared and s to be
o of d or epsilon
but in fact uh if you were to analyze
sparse jail specifically
for the purpose of getting a subspace
embedding like you know for this
random matrix what s m do i need to get
a subspace embedding
you can actually get an exponentially
better bound in s the truth is that
um this d can be replaced by something
like
you know log d
and you know but at the cost of you will
get like some log d here as well
so the kind of the tightest analysis
here is due to
michael cohen
but there's been you know there's other
work on this kind of before coin as well
so
you know the first the first paper to
show that you can get us a really really
sparse subspace embedding was by
uh clarkson and woodruff in 2013
then there were a series of papers
afterward that kind of got better and
better bounds
and down that line the one that has the
best bound is uh
is due to cohen
and also even the case for kind of this
fourier transform approach of ilona and
chazelle
rather than you know apply the jl
results from that over and apply it to a
net to get subspace embeddings
if you directly analyze that
construction for subspace embeddings
you can get a better bound as well
there's a lot to tell you unfortunately
we're out of time
i do i am teaching this course so if you
go to sketching
bigdata.org
slash fall 20 that's a course that i'm
teaching this semester on sketching
it's mondays and wednesdays 1 30
to 3 p.m uh pacific time
so actually the first lecture is in 25
minutes
um unfortunately you know there is there
is a cap on how many people can
participate so
it's open to all uc berkeley folks but
um for people in the program if you're a
long-term participant
you know then please join in i'm happy
to for you to join in but you know
it's not it's not it is a class it's not
so it's not open to the entire world
unfortunately
yes so that's all any questions
any questions
oh maybe i have a sort of naive question
in the first embedding yeah is the point
that the matrix pi should be constructed
without looking at the subspace
um so right so that right so should
probably be constructed without looking
at the subspace so
that's what's called you know oblivious
subspace embedding
but but i'm a bit positive you can look
at the space you are embedding a space
of dimension d
to something of larger dimension yeah
sorry so good so
here's a good point you know if i'm
allowed to actually so
so how is the subspace usually given as
input to me
it's usually given as like the column
space of a matrix
okay so i imagine that you know there's
some matrix a which looks like this
so i know that i know that it has you
know it's column space has low dimension
okay um
now i want to embed i want to find a
subspace embedding pi
such that you know pi has is roughly the
same
you know i want to say that um yeah i
want to find a good subspace embedding
for the column space of a so basically i
want that for all x
pi a x has roughly the same norm as ax
now if i'm given the matrix i could of
course you know
find a perfect subspace in betting i can
just say look
compute the svd a is equal to u sigma v
transpose
okay and then i think what i want to do
is i want to pick
um let's see so pi
ax i can just pick pi to be u transpose
if i pick pi to be u transpose then
actually not only do i get that these
things are whoops approximately equal
how do i oh here we go i actually get
equality right
i actually get that pi x equals ax if pi
is u transpose
the problem is that it's going to be
very expensive for me to
get this pi because i have to compute
the svd right
for example you know i might for
regression that you know
getting getting this svd is like just as
expensive as actually solving the
original regression problem so i haven't
gained anything
um now oblivion you know it's
so yes you know one advantage of
obliviously getting the pie
is that there's no computation time to
get the pi right because i don't have to
look at a however
there are non-oblivious methods that are
also fast
one of them is leverage score sampling
so there are algorithms out there that
will approximately compute what are
known as leverage scores so these are
numbers associated with the rows of a
and then i sample each row in proportion
to its leverage score
um and you know they're basically
they're
it's possible to do this quickly quickly
enough that it's meaningful for
applications
i didn't have time to get into leverage
score sampling but that is another
non-oblivious approach
great are the additional questions
okay then let's uh thank gianni for a
nice set of lectures
i think that's all for the sketching
if you need to know more you need to go
to the course okay
oh and for those for those people i
guess yeah um who want you know
don't want to sit in the course but
still want information from the course
there's a 2015 version
that is actually all all the lectures
were recorded
um the host is actually started okay
all the lectures are recorded and it's
on youtube it's publicly available
so just basically you know get rid of
this
fall 20 and then um
kind of there's a link that says you
know a previous version by jelani of
this course
go there click 2015 and in the 2015
version
you can find lecture videos
okay okay great that's all we are done
for today
okay bye thank you